foreign
Felicia joins us up next in Grand Rapids
Michigan Felicia welcome to the show
hi George and Ken thanks for taking my
call absolutely how can we help
yeah I have two really quick questions
um the first is we have uh we just
started Financial Peace University we
just finished lesson three awesome um so
we're on baby step one and we're halfway
through that and I realize that we have
an upcoming debt uh credit card bill
that was same as cash because my dog had
emergency surgery
um a couple months ago and that due date
is coming up soon in about four weeks so
we were wondering should we go ahead and
pay that so we don't get the interest or
should we just continue funding our
emergency fund and then put that into a
snowball well how much do you have in
the bank right now
um guess the 500 for our emergency fund
okay how quickly can you get the other
500.
um probably
a week or two okay and then what is this
uh the debt the same as cash credit card
debt how much uh it is uh 1200. okay and
it's due in four weeks so the question
is can we scrape together that kind of
money in four weeks can you guys do side
jobs side Hustle sell stuff
um I think so
there's only one answer here and it's
yes we will do whatever it takes to get
out of this because what's going to
happen and you know this now because you
read the fine print after the fact that
same as cash is not the same as cash
because the interest will be triggered
and it's going to be retroactive to the
beginning
so have you done the calculation on that
I I have not no I actually tried to call
them and wasn't able to get through
that's convenient they'll happily give
you the money instantly but to get in
touch with them it's a nightmare so my
guess is this is a very very high
interest even higher than your normal
credit card probably in the high 20s
maybe even 30s
that will be triggered retroactively so
I would do everything in my power to
clean up this debt uh what's your other
debts that you have
goes into my next question we have quite
a bit of Home things that we had to do
student loans and two cars and my other
question was about the Cars one of the
cars we are upside down on and
um I've been listening for about a month
now to you guys so I didn't know if we
should sell that but then I don't have
the 5000 to cover the difference yeah so
either you'd have to come up with a
difference and then sell it to cover the
loan or the other option is getting a a
small loan from a credit union to cover
the difference and then attacking that
smaller one I don't love the second
option but it's the only time I would
say it's okay to go into debt is to
clean up a mess like this when you're
underwater on the car are you underwater
on the other car
no okay what's that one worth
um I think it's where it's about
17 and we owe about 17 on it okay
I might consider selling that car today
and do private party and do your
research with uh carvana you can try car
wiser you can try vroom and see how much
money you can get for that car because
if you can get 18 for that car and you
owe 17 well now we can clean up this
emergency vet debt
okay and so I would do some drastic
things to get out of this mess What's
the total debt you're in
oh gosh
um it's over 180 000 including my
student home and that doesn't that
doesn't touch a mortgage
no oh man what's the biggest debt out of
the 180.
um the biggest get is
okay and then you said you did some
house stuff are you saying like you did
a HELOC what'd you do to finance the
repairs no
um yes we had uh we moved into a house
um and it had water in the basement
which became a whole big issue
um and we did not know that it had that
issue in the basement so we had to get
the whole basement fixed was it not
disclosed
um it was
I guess it it was but I mean how did an
inspector not catch that
I don't I don't know because the
bathroom tiles actually caved in and we
thought it was just a little water in
the bathroom but we started pulling up
the floor
well Felicia what is your household
income I hope it's really high
it's it's not as high as I want to be um
my husband and I combined make about
114. great can you put every penny from
the next few paychecks towards baby step
one and two and clean up this same as
cash loan and start these baby steps
yes yeah I I want to jump in it has the
every dollar app we have I've done the
beta thing to tell me when to put money
where but I am up for any suggestions
all right so then I'm gonna jump in on
that one and make a couple suggestions
so earlier in the call George asked you
are you willing to work extra hours take
on a second job you know whatever and
you were like I think so and I'm gonna
have a second job good but your husband
needs to get a second job and then you
need to sell stuff you work overtime
then he needs still using stuff I think
we need to do all right my point is I
want you to take off the limitations and
and stop thinking well I'm doing this
I'm doing this and I want to go how much
more can I do it's for a short season I
understand what I'm suggesting is not in
any way fun but I would tell you that
what I'm suggesting is doable
and I'm telling you to put the fire out
we do everything possible when the house
is on fire we don't go well I'm already
30 minutes into my Netflix show no it's
like put the fire out you know it's like
let's go and I think that you need that
urgency I understand you're tired I
understand you guys are already doing a
lot but we got ourselves into this we
can get ourselves out but it is going to
take Extreme Measures okay we're talking
urgency and I don't sense that in you
and I'm not beating up on you I'm just
trying to challenge you to say you can
do more sell everything get a fourth job
for a season I don't care I mean let me
just so people don't think I'm doing
rah-rah stuff okay
if I'm the husband and I'm going to
speak to a dude here if I'm your husband
I'm going all right
um
how many nights a week could I do an
overnight shift at Walmart making 22 an
hour
just for a short term or you know like
what how many nights could I do that you
stack that up times 10 nights 15 nights
in a month are you going to be exhausted
yeah but you could get out of this
situation pretty quick am I right George
yeah are you guys doing any investing
right now
no we stopped investing good are you
eating out right now
no do you get tax refunds every year
uh we do okay I would look at changing
my tax withholdings and I would get in
touch with a tax Pro because that means
the government's hanging on to your
money and right now you need that money
and so I want you to have a zero dollar
tax bill and make sure that you're
maximizing every dollar you have coming
in beyond that keep doing that budget
when you see any Bank transaction comes
in that you go we don't need to be
paying for that let's cut that
subscription no that's too much let's
not do that find any way you can get
really creative work as hard as you can
you guys have the income to do this it's
just a decision of are we going to go
all in or not
yes and me and Ken are more fired up
than you are at this point I think I'm
ready to tackle some dead I
hate my husband he's like oh
I'm actually more fired up than he is
well play this back to it got him on
board well you know what I just spoke to
him a few seconds ago rewind it for him
get on the YouTube and I'm speaking to
him right now come on dude man up right
now I will and he watched FPU as well he
went through lessons one two and three
he did okay let's check make sure he has
a pulse on him because I'm worried about
this guy does he understand the the fire
that you guys are in right now the mess
that you're in the interest rates that
are about to kick in
honestly I want to say no I think I
understand it more because I do all the
budgeting I do oh my goodness no Felicia
you've watched FPU that's all of that
that's not how this works this is a team
effort he needs to have input he needs
to have buy-in you're not going to do
anything for him that's why he's so
comfortable because you're taking on the
stress and weight of all this he doesn't
even know how broke he is show him on
paper show him tell him I'm stressed we
are not okay I am angry I'm frustrated
I'm anxious I can't live like this
anymore I need you to care as much as I
do